foreign
Kentucky says this I'm currently on baby
step two but I'm having a hard time
reconciling the debt snowball on credit
cards that can be paid off over time
without interest accruing as long as I
pay them off before the end of the
interest-free promo but I was hoping to
use the avalanche on my loans not my
credit cards in my mind I'd rather pay
extra money on the interest heavy loans
and diligently pay off my credit cards
thus taking advantage of the
interest-free promos side note I've cut
up all my credit cards and I'm sticking
to my zero budget diligently could you
help me understand the best course of
action hmm that sounds like Britney
wants to do her own course of action
personally yeah she's she's working her
own plan so what she's talking about
here is the Avalanche method of paying
off debt which says pay the highest
interest debts first and make your way
down regardless of the balance the debt
snowball method which is the one that
we've taught here for 30 years now is
pay off the smallest balance first
regardless of the interest rate that's
right which you know makes you scratch
your brain when you go well it's zero
percent interest why would I even pay
that off you know from my pers
experience and I believe the experience
of the millions of people who have
worked the baby steps and used you know
the debt snowball as their method we've
learned that you know when it comes to
money Dave says it all the time it's 80
per 80 Behavior 20 head knowledge right
and so there's something that builds up
in our behavior when we're working the
debt snowball for me it was about
getting those quick wins right George
when you put them from smallest to
largest you're able to knock out those
small debts quick and you feel like oh
my gosh I can do this you start to
believe that you can actually pay off
your debt and you know we we've said
that personal finance is 80 Behavior 20
head knowledge and the people who are
making these arguments they're focusing
on the head knowledge but I'm always
going if this isn't a life hack to try
to take advantage of the zero percent
you got yourself in a pile of debt and
so if you were so astute and disciplined
to pay off the highest interest rate
first you wouldn't have gotten into debt
in the first place that's right George
so there's a whole nother mentality here
going like I'm gonna hack the system
that I trapped myself in yeah and so we
found and it's not just a Dave thing
it's not just Dave Ramsey says and yeah
millions of people have done it if
that's not enough for you there are new
studies from Harvard Business review
from Texas A M saying the debt snowball
method works better that's right if
Harvard says it I'm biting and uh here's
the direct quote snowballing your debts
is from Chicago Tribune paying the
smallest to largest regardless of
finance charges might not make sense
mathematics technically but it just
might work better according to their new
academic study and so this isn't
anecdotal because we meet these people I
I don't I haven't met someone who's like
I am an avalanche debt-free screamer I
just don't meet them I don't meet them
either and I think it's because it's
harder to gain traction and so you stay
in the process longer and yes on paper
you would pay less interest if you could
do The Avalanche method with discipline
but the truth is we are human beings
yeah and we need that progress we are
wired to feel that problem we need to
feel the wind and it's it's tough
because when we think about money our
mind goes directly to the numbers it
goes to the math but in a lot of cases
money is not mostly about the math it's
mostly about your mindset and you
feeling like you're winning and you
feeling like you can succeed and
definitely the debt snowball sets you up
for that yeah staring at a giant pile of
debt that has the high interest rate and
going all right I gotta tackle this one
first it's like me starting running by
going all right I'm gonna run a marathon
and then work my way backwards to the 5K
oh gosh that doesn't make sense so why
do we do that with our money